there's like dudes in prison for like
two decades for selling like a little
bit of weed and and she's just walking
out of here with two bits she she
basically took maternity leave from
prison like what's happening I don't
understand
[Music]
all right what up we're here
Sam incredible shirt
um I mean enough said
not just one man to another I'd like to
issue a quick compliment and I'd like to
move on
someone in the comments said uh oh wow
Sam's dressed like a grown-up all I was
all I was wearing was it was a coat and
so I I'm sitting on top of his shirt
so I had to bring it back down I had to
let people know you know
I could play Both Sides here yeah so
Austin 316 baby
I still get that dog in you which I
think is going to be the next shirt we
make is the uh still got that dog in him
um
okay where do you want to start first of
all did you do anything crazy this
weekend because I feel like your
weekends are a lot more interesting than
mine this weekend I watched cops on
Sunday because that's what I do it's a
solid session of cops but then so I'm um
I I did this combine thing so like I
wanted to I set like a new fitness goal
every uh quarter and this year this
quarter I wanted to score average for a
wide receiver in the NFL combine if you
Google like NFL combine averages you can
find them and this Sunday I had to do my
bench press test which is 225 times or
225 pounds and I had to do it about 15
times uh and I just about hit 15 and so
my results for my combine tests I almost
scored average I just missed it a little
bit but mostly I was there wow yeah so I
had but but the big discrepancy is when
they do the combine they use an
electrical timer for the 40 and I did it
by hand so my hand time was the same as
the electric time typically electric is
is is
slower meaning you have to add a little
bit on the hand types but
I kind of did it I kind of did it this
was one of my favorite business ideas
that still I don't I'm not aware of
anyone has done
it's not my favorite in that I don't I
don't think this is going to be the best
business I just it's a product I wish
existed which is
a traveling combine for your town so
basically the way I was thinking about
it was for Youth Sports so you know the
market of like
33 year old guys who really want to test
themselves before they leave their
athletic Prime that's that's you and
that's a small Market but a big Market
is
parents who really think their kid is a
special snowflake
and so um I was like why don't they have
a version of the combine where you get
measured height weight you know aren't
wingspan speed agility strength vertical
leap all that
um and just do it for all kids who are
in like competitive Sports because like
you've seen that for like travel soccer
or travel baseball parents spend
thousands of dollars and like uproot
their whole life
just to kind of like pursue the kids
athletic dream which is maybe actually
the parents athletic dream and just be
able to say that yeah oh he's really
good yeah he's yeah he's he's playing
with kids two years older than him right
now they love that they love saying that
their kids playing with kids you know
yeah they're only there's 14 year olds
in that league and um and so you know I
think that that product is great because
it's basically the Tough Mudder for
little kids
so you would be able to charge I don't
know 150 dollars per kid to get tested
plus another 20 a year to keep it all on
file uh you know another 20 bucks to get
the photo or the video montage that
you're gonna get to post to social media
and then every year you'll come back and
get retested to see how did you do are
you getting better or you're getting
worse what's your what are your gains so
I think this could be a viable business
and I would love if this existed because
I would love to go I'd love to get my
kids tested or my my niece tested and uh
even myself would love to to love to
enroll so I'm taking this a step further
first of all I knew I was going to marry
my wife because when I met her father he
had the ideal calves so he had the ball
he had the ball in the calf wait well I
like yeah I think I got a bulk ass well
usually people who are explosive they
have like a ball like a little tennis
ball in their cap I saw I saw his like
skinny ankle with the ball in the calf
and I was like all right
skinny ankle has to go with it right
that's a thing oh yeah pretty sure
things skinny ankles you need a skinny
ankle you need a skin I remember I used
the data girl and she did not have a
skinny ankle and I was like I don't know
if I could do this I don't know if it's
gonna work it's not you it's me judging
you
that's a great way to put it and then I
um I remember Malcolm Gladwell had a
book and he says like if you're born uh
if you're the eldest in your class
you're more like you got to be born in
like September so that you missed the
August cut off so you get a full year to
go dominate those hoes and so I was like
we're thinking about where you know as
I'm thinking about Family Planning I'm
like where are we going to live what's
the school year cut off can we can we
fit it in right before that and then
this weekend I got out a piece of paper
and I'm like basically my life planned
is I don't wanna I wanna rent until I
buy a home that I want to live in
forever because moving sucks and like
the house that I bought now it was just
like oh this is good enough and then now
I'm like I don't want good enough I want
perfect and so I'm just like plotting
until and so I'm thinking about what
that right home is going to be and I
realize it has to have a five to ten
thousand square foot like Warehouse so
whichever sport they're in we're gonna
build that we're gonna build something
yeah yeah if it's if it's hockey
gymnastics doesn't matter what it is
we're building that there and that's is
gonna get awesome at that and so I'm
planning all that out now there's not a
lot of houses with a five to ten
thousand square foot Warehouse attached
here just gonna let you know you may not
have I'm building it well I'm gonna
build it I've already looked it up I've
already looked it up I'm building this
thing also I have a theory that because
my wife and I were from different like
very very different ethnicity uh
background don't get canceled I think
our kit I well I think what I'm saying
is I think if we you mix all of these
genes until one child hopefully they're
gonna be a super baby you know they
won't get sick they'll have strong
calves we'll see I don't know what's
funny but when you say it like that you
know it's strange but but acceptable
socially if you had just said the
opposite you're like you know the wife
we have the same background we're pure
then all of a sudden you stepped out of
bounds so uh no I want I want a diverse
kid they're gonna be a super baby
because my wife uh is is mixed race and
I'm telling you she doesn't get sick
there's like all these things about her
that like I like that like whenever she
takes Med lesson she never has the side
effects you know what I'm saying right
so I'm just saying she's a super baby uh
so we'll see what's gonna happen with
that I will keep everyone updated though
um we're we're waiting eagerly I've got
a few interesting topics you want to
talk about this Elizabeth Holmes thing
first really really quickly so funny
explain what what you what you saw I
don't have a New York Times subscription
by the way so I only saw the headline
and the photo
dude I I assume you pay for the New York
Times can you tell me what was in the
story and explain this whole thing I
will so basically on Sunday yesterday
today's Monday she uh Elizabeth Holmes
from theranos you know uh fraudster
whatever she the story of this is she
was convicted of defrauding investors
upwards of hundreds of millions of
dollars got sentenced to 12 years in
prison
she pulled some a wild move where she
had a baby and then the baby baby one is
two or three years old baby two is now
like six months old and she's making her
plea to the government saying actually I
have a newborn you can't put me in
prison and they bought it and they did
it and so they they delayed her prison
sentence I'm not sure how it's going to
end up New York Times did a big expose
on her
expose or like positive feature it
seemed like a positive feature does
expose mean negative because this was
not negative this was yeah incredibly
positive exposed it's like just like a
guy with an accent saying exposed face
exposed her as being a wonderful human
is what they did
uh because they make her sound like
Heavenly and I will read the headline
Liz Holm wants you to forget about
Elizabeth and the whole story is about
how Elizabeth was this Persona and how
her new persona is Liz and she's a
normal mom she speaks like a normal
woman you know Elizabeth Holm was known
as she would talk like this and she
would wear like a black turtleneck and
whatever and then she admits she's like
I did that because I was a woman I'm
blonde I want to be taken seriously so I
had a low voice but listen to this uh
and and the pictures of her now she's
got long hair she's wearing blue jeans
and she looks like a mom she looks like
me honestly if I'm a woman and you go
look at this picture we look alike
um but listen to this one she does he's
I mean she looks just like me it's like
Elizabeth it says Liz Holmes wants you
to forget about Elizabeth the black
turtlenecks are gone so is the deep
voice and she wants you to meet her new
persona a mom and and
this is embarrassing honestly for the
New York Times to do this is pretty
this is pretty embarrassing people get
mad at us for bringing some people on
the podcast to do interviews with
no no no New York Times posting this
photo of
sampar with a wig saying and then doing
this Rebrand from Elizabeth Holmes to
Liz Holmes Liz Holmes are you kidding me
and saying so a new persona this is
absurd listen to this story so
here's an expert I can't uh I can't
shake us up so Mr Evans is her husband I
think Billy Abbott so in the waning days
of Thrones Miss Holmes got a dog a
Siberian Husky named Balto last year
when a mountain lion carried Balto away
from the front porch Miss Holmes spent
16 hours searching the woods digging
through the brambles and poison oak
hoping to find them alive everyone knew
that he was dead but Miss Holmes kept
searching
she was relentless the certainty the
fanaticism it's the same way Miss Holmes
kept hanging on Toronto throughout
therados Miss Holmes eventually found
her beloved husky Balto in the woods but
by then the dog had been torn apart by a
mountain lion and it's this like whole
story about how her seeking her dog is
this her getting carried up in just the
fanaticism and she's really well
intentioned but she just got caught up
in it it's like pretty pretty wild and I
have to remind people
I wrote an article I actually posted it
on here I wrote an article in
2016. so I want to call myself I read
this in 2015 and the headline of my
article is the coverage of theranos is
utter and the first sentence is
Elizabeth Holmes has been thrusted into
the spotlight as a skateboard scapegoat
for all things wrong with Silicon Valley
but I find the media coverage around
theranos drama to be utter and
I explained why I think she didn't she's
not doing anything wrong and how she's
being hated on I left the article up
because I'm like you can't you can't
take down a mistake you got to leave it
up but I I fell for this and when I read
this article about New York Times
I just realized I think I'm just a
little
a little I fall for all this stuff
I read this and I'm like oh you're right
she's just like you and me like let's
let's not send her to prison I fall for
all this stuff
I mean look at this this is like there's
a picture of her and this guy and their
two babies sitting on a bunch of rocks
by the beach Barefoot do you see this I
don't know if you see this photo yeah
it's like yeah yeah yeah tweet it out
first of all it looks
you're using mid-journey what is this
why does this look so fake secondly like
this whole like you can't just get a new
haircut and drop half your name like if
I got a buzz cut and came on here and
said I'm shop hurry you can't be like oh
that's Shaw Shaw's a great shot's a
great dude it doesn't care about money
shot is a tweet controversial things
he's a different kind now he's a dad and
then I take my kid to a place with some
rocks take a photo that doesn't work
like you know it is working though it is
working though this is the greatest do
you know who James Todd Smith III is
no who's that LL Cool J baby oh my God
at least James Todd Smith had the
decency to like fully change it up and
try to get a whole new persona this is
crazy that she is uh
that they're just trying to make this
happen I mean I don't understand what's
going on
it's working though she's not she's not
in jail she was supposed to report to
prison like three weeks three weeks ago
there's like dudes in prison for like
two decades for selling like a little
bit of weed and uh
and and she's just walking out of here
with two but she she basically took
maternity leave from prison like what's
happening I don't understand
that's exactly what happened that's
exactly what happened you know what and
you know what's another thing that's
kind of crazy is do you ever follow Ross
Albright on or ulbrich on Twitter so
Ross Albrecht is the guy who killed or
he ran Silk Road and Silk Road was like
a drug Marketplace and at the time in
like three years it did like two billion
dollars in sales he uh also is accused
of
um did a murder for hire for three
people or four people none of the people
died but the police took pictures of the
people pretending to be dead and sent it
to Ross and then he hired the fake
killer which was was the police he hired
them again and again and so anyway he
got life in prison and he tweets about
it
I've got one of those guys that thinks
that he doesn't he he should go to
prison but dude life is a long-ass time
for for
eign
that's all the time and he's tweeting in
prison and I feel so sorry for these
guys I fall I fall for all this stuff
I'm you know I'm just I'm soft I think
yeah yeah it sounds like it okay so you
think Ross is you think Ross deserves
like I thought like 25 years is isn't it
actually one of the life sentences isn't
a life sentence actually only like 22
years or something
no he got life without parole like he's
he's in there forever and he probably
has multiple life sentences right and it
went all the way up to uh the Supreme
Court so they so basically the only way
I believe he's gonna get out of prison
is if a president uh says uh what was it
called were they um
uh put you out of prison I forget the
word but uh that's like the only way
that he's ever gonna get out and I don't
need to like get him confused but my
nephew Ross yeah
a telemarketer needs to call Biden
pretend to be uh well we have your
cousin yeah someone from Indio and he's
act like they work at Apple or the IRS
I have a few more topics what do you got
what do you got that's interesting so I
want to tell you about a a I have a I
have a feature here I got a billy of the
week for you
[Music]
[Applause]
a million dollars isn't cool you know
it's cool a billion dollars it's been a
little while since I have a good had a
good Billy of the week I kind of felt
one bubbling up a little bit and sure
enough I got one okay so here's I'm
gonna tell you some things about this
person's career and uh you can you might
know who it is you may not okay so this
is somebody who's um
so they've had a very successful
business career sold a company uh to
Berkshire Hathaway actually so they sold
a a company that had done five billion
dollars in a 10-year span of sales okay
wow impressive
um
just now yeah yeah they do yeah yeah I
got one eyebrow up all right let me see
if I get that other eyebrow
um they've won an Emmy they were a
manager of Run DMC and 50 Cent was their
intern at the at the time huh so music
dominated business dominated
uh how about uh what's uh what's an Emmy
and Emmy is um the Musical TV I think oh
yeah I mean it's actually TV so this
person uh they wrote Jingles for for for
TV and stuff like that and that's that's
one way they made their their bones but
they also managed to Run DMC which is
the hottest rap group in the world at
the time in 50 Cent I think I know who
you're talking about they also uh you're
a you're you're a fit guy I see I see a
cutter too in in the in those arms the
uh this guy's run over 50 marathons has
run a hundred miles in uh 24 hours and
actually had David Goggins live with him
for 30 days and ended up writing a book
about it sounds pretty pretty
interesting he's a part owner of an NBA
team
does he have a successful wife that's
the best part about it in his marriage
he's not even the most successful one
married who I someone who I think is the
youngest female billionaire
um in the world so incredible incredible
pull on his part
um let's see do I have anything else
good about him here well I think you
missed something very interesting the
company that did five billion five or
ten billion or whatever you said
billions in sales wasn't that a jack
company it was a private jet company
fractional ownership of private jets
the person uh oh there's a few more they
also were a key partner in uh in a cpg
brand everybody wants to start uh start
a cpg brand see it in store shelves one
day did that ziko coconut water you ever
heard of that one sold to Coca-Cola yeah
got it everywhere
this is something they also wrote I
think they also wrote the Jingle the
official jingle for the New York knit
Knicks for something right it sure did
sure did
um in addition to that
sells online courses and he's like one
of us he's just like us these
billionaires
I'm talking about you would you like to
to guess who I'm talking about here
so uh Jesse itzler is the ability of the
week this guy's got a fascinating career
right I I am
like everybody's got a different thing
they admire the thing I admire the most
in people is people who play the game
their way on their on their terms and
their rules and one of the ways you see
that is people who have multiple
chapters in their career where they're
able to turn the page to do something
completely different
so for somebody who started out in the
kind of like jingle writing business to
then be like a manager of a of a famous
you know uh rap Squad to then starting a
private jet company to then living in a
monastery with monks to them becoming an
endurance athlete to then becoming an
NBA owner to them doing coconut water
like I love people who have done
multiple chapters of their career and I
want to kind of talk about some of these
different things he did I kind of run
you through his timeline here of what
he's done yeah and I I read the book
it's called living with seal it was
basically the book I think that got
David Goggins to be famous it was
awesome it was a good book
oh was that before David Goggins kind of
was like super well known
yeah in the book I don't even think he
mentions David's name and then it came
out oh it came out who this person was I
think he Jesse was at a marathon and he
saw this guy and David Goggins you know
everyone knows he's like a six foot six
black dude he's like ripped and that's
not typically what an ultra marathon
runner looks like and he became friends
with them and hired him so here's what
he did so he started uh back in 1995
started something called Alphabet City
sports records and these guys were
making basically like music
um
Sports Marketing music production and
they do it for three years they sell it
for four million dollars to uh
to some like you know small a small
acquisition so get there that's how he
got his first million and uh stays there
for a little bit then they they set him
in the same guy I think uh start Marquis
Jets so Marquee Jets was basically like
how do you buy hours on a private jet
without buying the private jet so how
can you get more people access to
private jets and so it'd be like you
would buy 25 hours of flight time on a
private jet and it was like a debit card
you get to just go use it then you get
to buy more hours whatever whatever you
want if you get a whole bunch of people
doing that you might be able to use
these Jets a lot more efficiently than
they're being used when just one person
owns it that's sitting on a Runway 90 of
the time was that a big business
so they never really they never fully
released any numbers the one thing he
said is they did 5 billion in sales in a
10-year period which is a lot of yeah
but I'm wondering I'm not sure if I'm
not sure of the economics of that though
because it's like if you sell they
didn't sell Jets but if you sold Jets
like that doesn't necessarily like a jet
cost 20 million dollars you actually
only make 500k from it I don't you know
what I'm saying yeah I don't actually
here's what he said if it's legit here's
what he said in an interview I'll put it
this way we were extremely profitable we
did cumulative 5 billion in sales 5
billion over 10 years so he says we were
extremely profitable so we'll take that
I also think that when you sell to
Berkshire Hathaway they're not in the
habit of buying unprofitable businesses
so
um they sold well they sold to Berkshire
Hathaways company netjets which is like
you know one of their one of their
companies so they sold to netjets so
then uh zika coconut water so these guys
have been around for four years
he partners with them and uh goes to
them and says look let me invest let me
help you guys grow this thing it was
kind of like small at the time and in
the same year he invests he gets
Coca-Cola to invest 15 million and then
eventually they sell the whole thing to
Coca-Cola I'm not sure how much they
didn't disclose that
um but basically in a five-year period
four or five year period he helps ezeko
coconut water go from kind of unknown to
pretty well known and uh and sold in
2013 too to Coke
um
they've done this thing they've done a
similar thing they invested in kind bars
uh as well uh he's got like basically
he's got this
brand investor group called 100 mile
group and that's what they do they've
also they invested in something called
sheets energy strips with LeBron and
Serena Williams and a whole bunch of
famous people that one failed it was
like caffeine you just put a strip on
your tongue and it melts and it gives
you like energy uh but that one didn't
didn't work out uh Pitbull also a angel
investor in that one so uh he bought a
he was part of the group that bought a
piece of the the Atlanta Hawks which is
I think where I think he lives in
Atlanta I'm not sure yeah they have a
house in Atlanta and there I follow them
on Instagram he's always in I think he
owns a fat townhouse in New York he's
also RV I've seen them like RV like in
this huge tour bus looking RV thing
I also think he has like six kids too
the guy does it all yeah I know
quadruple threat dare I say so he uh so
he also started this thing called 29029
Everlast everesting and so what it is is
basically they rent a mountain and they
bring together like food music thick and
it's a it's an endurance event where you
can walk run climb crawl whatever you
want to do up this mountain and then you
take the gondola back down until and you
keep going up and down up and down until
you've done 29 000 and 29 feet which is
the height amount ever so it's like a
way to hike Everest without going to
Everest without doing the the extreme
risk of uh of surviving Everest he's got
like his all-day running club you
probably know about this one it's a paid
membership club for for runners
basically 400 bucks for the for the year
and uh he's wrote two books he was a
rapper back in the day back in 1991 he
was a rapper called Jesse James and uh
wrote the Jingle the New York Knicks
theme song Go Go NY go and uh I mean
just done it all really really
incredible like Variety in his career I
think this is prolific prolific good
word prolific the guy's prolific was he
me and then his wife is Sarah Blakely
who
sold Spanx I think it was yeah
and Spanx was just acquired for like two
or three billion or something like that
do you know what the final it was just
bought by Blackstone
BlackRock or Blackstone whichever one is
the one that buys companies bought it
yeah and if if I remember correctly that
company was entirely bootstrapped 1.2
billion
1.2 billion I think she owned most of it
yeah
so like
they're killing it imagine being Jesse
and not the most successful one
financially in the relationship that's a
good catch
yeah what's like the best thing I wanted
to make a joke there about like you know
in the house he does the dishes or
something like that what's like the uh
what would have been the joke there for
for him being like uh the subordinate in
the house
I think he manages the people who do the
dishes at this point but he's definitely
managing people no that I I've been
following them for a while Jesse's been
he kind of like became the self-help
Guru and I was turned off by him and
then I actually started following him
more and I was like Oh no you're
actually pretty awesome and he's the one
he's made uh so he's been on the
Forefront of a lot of really popular
Health Trends so he was really into
saunting for a long time and now like
hot and cold exposure is quite popular
he's been doing that for years uh he's
also been doing fasting I would follow
him like years ago and he would go like
five days without eating and he would
try all these weird help things and now
a lot of these things are popular he was
he's been doing it for a while and in
his book uh it's called living with seal
he basically found David Goggins David
Goggins lived with them for 30 days it's
an awesome book it's a really good book
I mean he tells all these crazy stories
about this guy and so I'm a big fan of
Jesse one of the ones I got to know him
I was turned off when I like first heard
about him and then I realized he's
pretty badass what do you say that I had
the same same reaction I saw him just in
a bunch of like public speaking slash
like ads being like you gotta take my
course and do whatever and I was like
you know usually typically people who
are like pretty self-promotional with
that sort of stuff
it's like their their main business is
actually the talking uh like their main
business is the
selling you on how to be successful not
like having been successful themselves
that's just like a general rule of thumb
so I was really surprised when I looked
into it I was like oh wait actually this
guy's like pretty prolific he he's
pretty legit I'm surprised I had that
opinion of him though I kind of bucketed
him mentally as like online business
Guru guy
um you know but maybe I don't know maybe
maybe that was a total
mischaracterization now that I see kind
of all the stuff he's done I also think
one really interesting thing is uh have
you heard about his pickles thing
no what's that so by the way I invited
him on the podcast we follow each other
on Twitter so I DM them last night and I
was like hey you should come on I want
to hear I want to hear about some of the
stories that the experiments that didn't
work out because this is all the the
wins I I'm sure if you're a guy who's
tried this many different things you had
to have a bunch of uh a bunch of you
know trial and error along the way so he
posted this on Instagram last month he
goes why I'm excited about pickles
all caps and he goes last week I said I
wanted to buy or partner with a pickle
company and boxes of pickles have been
shown in my house all week it's exciting
I'm doing a live taste test this week uh
they're all so different lots of people
asking me why pickles here's why
he goes first of all can you name five
pickle companies
I hate pickles I don't know can you name
any pickle companies there's probably
only two or three that I like to buy I
buy a lot of pickles I'm a big pickle
guy yeah big of the Pickled pickle scene
so he says can you name five pickle
companies exactly it's a crowded Market
but not many dominant players second
pickles are underrated Americans eat 20
billion pickles a year and there is no
buzz in the category not much fun for
creativity all the packaging is the same
number three the average American eats
nine pounds of pickles per year number
four the average American household buys
a new jar every 53 days number five
purely pickles are a big deal
entrepreneurs look to make things better
often those new ideas come in the form
of products they use daily they get
excited when they see a new Lane and I
see a new Lane here and so
um he created this thing this pickle
company called Hoya Yaya pickles and
he's like this is the day of our new
company we just need the perfect picture
is that like a Yiddish thing
I have no idea well pickles are like a
popular amongst Jewish people he's
Jewish just Hoya is that like a maybe
it's like a Yiddish name I don't know
it's a funny name and he said it says if
you go to their bio they only have 2 000
followers right now but I'm gonna follow
this I want to hear the story play out
he goes we're crowdsourcing our brand
while we create the best pickle company
while we find the best pickle company to
partner with DM if you have a clean
ingredient pickle company and then he's
basically like uh like it's got to feed
and it's like here's a picture of Adam
Sandler casually eating a jar of pickles
it's like he's just trying to build a
speaker company he's trying to do the
coconut water thing again for pickles
this time and uh I think we could
probably pull it off dude pickles are
awesome I'm I like Jesse we should get
them on if Jesse if this makes it to you
this will make it to you anytime yeah
remember when you I went to hustlecon
your conference and um there was the guy
who created method soap and he created
Ollie vitamins he created Welly
Band-Aids he created three hit consumer
you know cpg Goods uh that were sitting
around something Eric Ryan I think is
his name it's him
yeah he's like a he's like a he's like a
flamboyant looking guy he wears like
these bright glasses and he his hair is
combed uh exotically I like that guy
yeah yeah exactly he looks like he uh
you know was born inside of a Warby
Parker or something so he uh he was on
stage and he gave a great talk at your
conference one of the things he said
they were like how do you it was like
how do you come up with ideas like which
you did Band-Aids you did vitamins you
did soap what how do you choose where do
you see the open space and he said
basically the same thing that Jesse just
said he goes I walk down the aisles of a
grocery store
and I just wait till I see a sea of
sameness so basically a sea of sameness
is an area where there's a shelf where
you see like a ton of products
with no differentiation it's just a
bunch he's like for soap go look at the
sobile it was just green bottles of the
same product in the same shape sitting
there everywhere he's like so we came
out with a different bottle it was blue
and had clean ingredients that was going
to be our thing and that was method so
he's like go to the Band-Aid section
same thing CEO of sameness whereas we
took a different approach and he's like
Band-Aids we're trying to all be this
like nude color that was like same color
as your skin he's like but nobody's skin
is actually that color so it's just like
this like kind of you know you're just
trying to like hide something it goes we
you know we believe you know your every
cut is a badge of honor it's a great
story to tell and so we want to put a
badge on that on that uh on that wound
as that stands out and that was his
approach to that one or whatever and so
same thing with the vitamins aisle he's
like the vitamin dial was just a bunch
of labels that all said like vitamin D3
b12s you know C blah blah blah he came
in and with Ollie they have like a
different looking jar and it'll say like
better sleep or it'll say better hair
and nails or whatever right like it'll
say the benefit of the vitamin not the
vitamin itself and so just taking a
slightly different approach to these
like kind of stale categories was the
was the idea and I think if you go down
the pickle aisle probably a pretty stale
category it's probably as a sea of
sadness and so I think this is gonna
work
well Jesse if you're listening come on
man come on
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
we were I was one time I was doing one
of these events and we were looking at
speakers and we typically had never paid
speakers and for some reason his name
popped up and like his agent sent or
some agent sent like how much his fee is
and it was like a hundred thousand
dollars to get him come to come and talk
so the guy's killing it and a variety of
places that's right um all right I have
another interesting person
um and I'm gonna explain why I found
this person
have you ever heard the phrase the way
you do one thing is the way you do
everything hate that phrase why do you
hate that phrase because I do a bunch of
things terribly that I'm like does that
mean I'm gonna do everything terribly uh
so I hate it because if it's true I'm in
trouble so I believe that that phrase to
be true and I believe it to be true
because I've always I've got on myself
because I'm not entirely like you but
I'm a little bit like you where I like
to like you know free ball it I free
ball lines you know what I'm saying I
just I try to figure out as I go but my
lack of discipline and my lack of
process sometimes really hurts me and so
I'm trying to make up for that and so
I've over the past couple years I've
been obsessed with the phrase the way
you do one thing is the way you do
everything so for example you're late
for this pod you are also late for your
kids Home Depot class that's right so
the way you do that one thing is when
you do everything and it's like one of
the that's one of the reasons why the
military they make you make your bed in
the morning is because they say if you
start making your bed in the morning
that means you're gonna eat breakfast
the correct way that means you're gonna
run the right way which inevitably
you're gonna fight the right way and so
like I believe in that and so I was
looking for examples of that and so have
you ever heard of this company called uh
racketon this is a company called
rackington it's basically like Amazon in
Japan it started by this guy named uh
his name is he goes by Mickey so Mickey
uh Mickey Tani is his name and he's
similar to like Jeff Bezos in Japan
where he's like those kind of like
pretty hardcore guy but he's lovable and
he's he's a Titan of Industry so rakitin
is like Amazon in Japan it has 32 000
employees 14 billion in Revenue this
huge thing
and I love reading about Japanese
entrepreneurs because there's something
about their culture that fascinates me
and they have uh this thing where he has
like uh a handbook that he gives every
employee and I got a hold of that
handbook a few years ago and I read it
and one thing that stuck out to me was
in chapter zero the very first thing
that they have you do the whole what
that chapter is about is it's called the
uh the book is called the basic
principles but in chapter zero it's
called
they outline how at their offices they
don't have any janitors and the reason
why they don't have any janitors is
every Tuesday at four o'clock they have
an hour of clean time which basically
means that
uh so no janitors coming by but every
week at the same time in the morning
everyone at rackington from the CEO to
the lowest level staff cleans their
workspace they take out rags and spray
bottles they clean off their surfaces
they pick up trash they get on their
hands and knees and they polish the legs
of the chairs and it's part of the
company of the culture and uh it's been
like that since the beginning since the
company was around and it's the purpose
of it is to foster a sense of ownership
he says we do this activity to remind
ourselves that everything the company
does is relevant to each and every one
of us to keep a sense of direct
involvement top of mind it's also an
opportunity to reaffirm that the entire
company is a team by having everyone
regardless of position work together on
the same task and I read this when I was
leading the hustle and I tried to make
that a thing and it didn't work no one
no one got into it no one got it I'm so
glad you said that last part because
I've done this so many times I've just
Michael scotted it so many times where I
will read something or hear something or
have some kind of crazy idea but usually
it's I hear I heard some cool person did
some cool thing
and then I'll try it in our office and I
just got these looks like okay
and then within four days the thing is
gone and I'm like oh man I really needed
a different like force of will or
Charisma or some like a leather jacket I
needed something I'm missing something
to make this thing because the way you
do one thing is the way you do
everything man you didn't do a good
enough job neither did I and once I
failed at that I realized I need to do
this stuff even more and so with Hampton
with Hampton I'm trying to figure out
what is that thing you know that we can
all do and I realize right now it's our
Zoom setups so I actually I linked it
down here in our document but I have
this I have this so if you go to scroll
all the way down to where it says Zoom I
have this document called how to look
good on camera and the reason I do that
is because when people apply to Hampton
we interview everyone and then me or Joe
or someone else goes and watches the
interview to see if that person should
be approved and I saw one of our guys
his name's Alex pattis he works at
Hampton and he's awesome but I saw that
his camera setup was horrible I was like
dude this looks like a ransom video you
filmed on a Nokia cam camera like this
looks really bad and so we're gonna have
to like we're gonna have to like fix
this you know first impressions matter
and so I created this guide on how to
make your zoom camera look good and then
we gave everyone a budget to go and buy
like the proper lighting and things like
that and that's like my one thing that
I'm trying to implement now whereas like
I won't talk to you unless your zoom
camera looks great it has to look good
and it doesn't have to look like
professional like you and me like a DSLR
camera but it's Gotta look pretty good
and you can make it look pretty good
with like 500 and so we're making
everyone have their zoom camera look
great so first of all this dock is
hilarious and the video of the picture
of the guy who looks like the ransom guy
is hilarious
um I think you're close but I don't
think you quite got it I hate to I hate
to do that too tell me more as a friend
to just pop the bubble like that but
I think you got half of it right meaning
I think you
Your solution is great but you pick the
wrong area meaning this is too logical
it's too quantifiable why they why this
is a good idea you said well first
impressions matter everybody agrees with
that and you say well you're doing sales
essentially for the company so you need
to like show up the right way
it's almost like you could calculate the
ROI the beauty of the Polish the chairs
and your leg chairs or whatever is that
it's unnecessary same thing with the
make your bed in the morning first thing
or wake up at 4 30 in the morning just
to harden yourself as a person or take a
cold shower is
It's gotta have some it's got to be
something you kind of don't want to do
or seems unnecessary to do and it's like
but that's the point so what's an
example this is almost like you kind of
gotta do it this is almost like uh yeah
it makes sense I agree I'm not taking a
leap of faith here I'm just doing what
you know maybe I was held back my money
here in the tech setup and I just get
around to it
um so I think it's good but I think you
need something that's a little bit more
story worthy which is like yeah at
Hampton we made everybody
blank and I think if you say with
everybody fix their camera setup it's
not going to have that same Showmanship
it's not gonna have the same uh
punchiness as if it's something that was
completely unnecessary to do so I've got
to figure out what that thing is though
but I but I definitely want it I want I
want a stick oh yeah I love a good stick
yeah I love a good stick I'm a big fan
of sticks I think they add a lot right
now my current stick is your your zoom
camera has to look good it's Gotta look
great you get it everybody has a small
tattoo on their ankle of a date five
years of the future which is when
Hampton will be worth a billion dollars
right you have to go you had to go
pledge baby you gotta go get Brandon if
you're gonna get on this but I love that
stuff and that's another thing we're
thinking about Hampton is we're like
What rituals do like our members need to
have in order to get them bought in and
so I'm like trying to like research like
fraternities and sororities but I love
this in the same way that Tony Robbins
his shtick is that uh what's it called a
firewalk yeah walking a coal
which like isn't even that big of a deal
is it have you watched on coal yeah I
did it I've done it twice at his events
um
yeah it was like a pretty sanitary thing
isn't it yeah it's right there's no
there's no no risk in doing this
basically he's like yeah you gotta get
your mindset right you got to get in the
state and when you're in state you could
do anything it's like I'm pretty sure
that like they basically just make you
stand on this thing that's wet before so
you get like moisture on the bottom of
your foot and then you can just walk
across these coals and it's not gonna
like unless you stood there and stayed
there it won't uh make it past that
layer of water or whatever this I'm like
it's just actually science that if
you're if you walk across this much
thing for this much time with this much
water on your foot you're not gonna get
in you're not gonna have any problems
and so a great actor dude a great actor
needs a good set and good props and I'm
like reading this book about JP Morgan
JP Morgan was this guy in the his Gilded
Age whatever rich guy and he one time
was trying to settle an agreement with
like five different like Union heads of
like different steel companies and he
goes come out to my boat and we're gonna
go for a boat ride and we're gonna
discuss he gets on the boat and he goes
all right everyone any like the the
pilot of the boat uh like goes off in a
rowboat he goes we don't have a um
Captain uh we're stranded out here until
we settle a deal we are not leaving
until the deal is done and it's that
Pizzazz that show midship every great
every great actor needs a good set he he
set up that set wonderfully and I'm
constantly looking for what's our ritual
what's our SEC going to be how can I
like add the showman before and I
studied a bunch of different like kind
of rituals basically anybody that has a
really strong Community what what is it
everything from actual Cults uh European
soccer clubs where the fans are just
insane
um like I went to Duke and we used to
live in a tent for three months which is
basically living in a line to try to get
into the big game really and everybody
behave everybody behaves a certain way
people don't even like basketball or
live in an intent for three months just
to do this just because they get swept
up in the rituals the movement
um I remember I never been before man
but I talked to people I was like dude
there's something about burning man that
gets people to act totally differently
than their normal behavior what is it
and they told me that when you enter
burning man I might butcher this because
again I've never been but when you get
to Burning Man so you first you wait in
line in your car basically for hours
hours and hours trying to just get to
the entrance and when you get to the
entrance apparently you kind of like you
get out and they give you a name
they give you like your new name your
burner name and then you like roll
around in the sand or some like
that have you heard this
yeah like Firefox lion boy yeah and then
you roll in the sand and like that's
like your like entrance thing or
whatever yeah um I did something at my
last company that was kind of like that
which was uh
just roll around the streets of Soma no
no I'm just joking we had uh we had a
meeting once I was ever everybody had
been at the company for like the the was
it like the the hepatitis huddle
everyone's gonna go out in the streets
of Soma and roll around
hahaha
it's syringe Sunday baby get on the
ground yeah
with our body the uh but I did this
thing where after six months of working
I um I called a team meeting and I
basically gave a presentation to the
team about each one of them and I
basically said this is this this is Sam
this is the same story if this is Sam's
superpower
and I gave everybody a superpower and I
was like this is
um this is Derek Derek was our designer
I said designers are notoriously they're
just artists they're fickle they need
inspiration they you give them a
deadline artists are terrible with
deadlines and uh but Derek's superpower
is that Derek is the mailman
he delivers every day of the week except
on Sundays and I was like Derek if you
give him something at 9am he will have
it to you by 5 PM every single day
without fail except Sundays you message
Derek he's not going to get back to you
and I was like which is like it's
totally not true but you've just
implanted that into him it was like
mostly true everybody's thing was like
believable believably true but it's
amazing that everybody started living up
to it everybody started referring to him
as the mailman and then he would like
sure enough he would always deliver them
he never didn't deliver because he had
to live up give people a reputation to
live up to
um with fur Khan I was like fur Khan
his superpower is that he'll always lend
you five dollars whenever you ask for it
just you asked for him he's got you
he's always got some change on him
always always good for 20. he um I was
like he belts and I was like he
is just a melter you can't
bring around him it's like
radioactive it'll just start to melt
right away and so
he otherwise the Freak Out was pretty
like uh direct and I think some people
you know were intimidated by him and
they felt like he was like you know
criticizing them when he would say
something but then it reframed it as
he's just using the super he's just he
just he's great at identifying and
melting it's not you it's it's
the that he's melting and so um so
I tried to do that for everybody and I I
really that was one of the few like
management random like random experiment
sticks that actually worked that people
really like they liked that they had a
superpower
and then they kind of I named it and
then I reinforced it and people uh
people started using that one actually
in the office whereas most things was
just me trying to make fetch happen and
they're like it's not gonna happen well
I remember early in my career like I
worked the only job I ever had this guy
had a shtick and he would try to he
would get everyone to clap like slow
clap before yeah yeah
it was like that and I remember thinking
like this is so stupid and then after a
couple weeks I was like all right
yeah now I'm a little bit older and I'm
like uh stick is good a good stick is
great like it's really good A lot of
that like performative stuff I just
think I'm I'm too cool for this I don't
need this and then you realize like no
man humans are not logical we need
emotion like this emotional stuff
matters like the difference between a
highly motivated person and who's using
their emotions effectively is
significantly better than someone I mean
that's like if you look at like
different Wars like you could like look
at like who is like fired up the right
way versus who's not and it really has a
massive difference
I think that uh leadership basically if
you want to be a leader like three
things are true the first is that you
have a higher standard for yourself than
anybody else has for you so it doesn't
really matter what your job title is but
if you hold yourself to a higher
standard then your manager holds you to
you are a leader and so that's the first
to me first definition of leader second
is somebody who understands what the
emotional state is and what it needs to
be it could transfer it so basically
anybody who can understand that morale
is low it needs to be high they can
shift the mood they can shift the energy
or everybody's a little too comfortable
we need to get a sense of urgency they
they understand the state of the
emotional state and they know how to
shift it that's two and then the third
is they see things how they actually are
not worse than they are not better than
they are how they actually are and then
they paint a picture of how it's going
to be better than it currently is to me
those are the things are you reading
this are you reading this off something
no that's just wow straight off the door
that's a good little I think that's a
good little uh a good little thing the
next tweet there you go that's a great
one actually if I if I wasn't a retired
Twitter artist I would have tweeted that
one
um I got one other quick one for you I
want to read you Justin yeah yeah I've
been eager to see what you're gonna say
I want to read you something so this was
uh you're on that Justin Mayer's tip so
we talked about just the mayor's at the
last pod Justin's a very fantastic
entrepreneur you clearly been reading
his blog you've been obsessing
I actually somebody sent this to me um
afterwards I haven't I've only read this
screenshot that they sent
um somebody sent this to Ben they go I
feel like every time you've done this
last time you read you said you're
reading a book and I was asking about
the book and you're like I've actually
uh you you go I just read this awesome
book and turns out you're five pages in
yeah it's awesome
you love at first sight you know we need
to know all right so here's what it says
here's here's a quote from his blog
it says I give the same advice to
friends who want to start a company
startups are momentum plays that's the
key thing startups are momentum plays
you choose you choose the idea you are
most excited about you put a date on the
calendar for three to six months at that
date you're allowed to reflect on your
commitment level until then you do not
spend any time questioning it should I
be chasing xid over there should I be
doing this over here no you put blinders
on for a period of time you allow
yourself to dig into the problem space
and spend your early time actually
working on the thing versus
intellectualizing is this the exact
perfect right and obviously huge thing I
should be working on at least that's
what I've struggled with when working on
something new
uh startups are momentum plays and how
you have to put blinders on for a period
of time to just actually do the thing
versus intellectually like constantly
questioning or considering the Thing
versus 10 other things and paralysis by
analysis
um what do you think of that yeah I've
told you about this I think I have this
thing called worry time where I say like
all right today of the week I can worry
about these things once that hour is up
no more worry time it's only due time I
can I can go back and reflect and figure
out my worries and figure out what's
like legit and what's not at a later
date sometimes I'll do it six months out
so like when I was searching for kind of
like where you are now when I was
searching for which company to start I
go all right for the next six months
it's plan mode all I'm gonna do is read
consume I'm not going to decide a thing
I'm just going to consume and read and
then at the end of six months then I'll
make a decision and uh so I I love
setting like clear dates where you can't
do anything I also love momentum so when
someone talks to me about starting a
business I go try and see if you can get
sale sales in the next 24 hours like
what's the least amount what's the
smallest thing you could do to get a
sale in 24 hours because the second you
make one dollar if everything it feels
like changes it's like as if you had
poor eyesight now you have glasses on it
like that that little that little bit of
eyesight gives you a boosted energy and
you feel significantly better to get the
second dollar which makes getting to 100
and then a thousand easier which at a
thousand you go to a million so and you
have this really cool line you say a b z
where you go you worry about step a and
how to get to B and then don't worry
about anything else but you can think
about Z occasionally which is like your
big motivating factor but don't think
about you know all the whatever the
other letters are yeah
if this reminds me of something I've
seen a bunch and I have a sensitivity
towards it because I did this which is
uh
a lot of people want to do like startup
Studio idea lab I want to do multiple
things at once basically
so they want to do
parallel entrepreneurship I ran an idea
lab for five six years or so and
I loved it because it's the most fun
thing you could possibly do it's like
you get I had a blank check and an
awesome team and I could pursue not just
any idea many ideas at the same time and
I could go from meeting to meeting to
meeting and have all this amazing
variety of Adventures and challenges and
ups and downs and it was like I felt
like I got 20 years of experience at
four
but notice that I said experience
instead of success because it was a lot
of lessons learned and a lot of skill
sharpening it wasn't a lot of winning
and if you would have had to have
sticked to one idea do you think that
would have been better or if you would
have had a smaller budget
sticking to one idea would have been far
better or just I'll give you kind of the
three options so there's what I was
doing which is parallel entrepreneurship
so you basically take multiple ideas and
you pursue them in parallel
um this is the easy trap to follow to
once you already have a win under your
belt this is why you've seen
um you know Mark pickis with Zynga
create an idea lab Kevin Rose created an
idea lab the guy from Uber created an
idea lab the guy from uh you know who
whatever there's there's like 10 of
these examples out there that's usually
successful founder wants to do startup
still
but has
too many interests too many ideas more
ideas than time so they create a lab a
studio that's going to create multiple
hits is the idea and almost none of them
have any hits whatsoever
um zero zero is the is the average and
the median for these for these uh
Studios that don't it doesn't work it
doesn't work for a bunch of reasons I
could get into but it's this form of
parallel entrepreneurship very sexy but
uh not great for actually winning so
there's parallel then there's serial
entrepreneurship serial entrepreneurship
is like the Jesse itzler thing which is
like I'm gonna do this for this period
of time and then I'm gonna do a
different thing for the next period of
time or I'm going to take this one thing
and if it doesn't work I'll pivot it
into something else and then I'll try
that for a few years but I'm gonna give
each one a several year you know chapter
basically of of effort and focus and
like full intensity on one one thing but
then I'm willing to switch what the one
thing is I'm not trying to run the same
company for a decade uh or stay in the
same industry for for 25 years of my
life I'm gonna switch around I'm gonna
hop around so that's cereal and then
there's the last one which is repeat
entrepreneurs the person who actually
does the same company or stays in the
same space it's like uh I created one
d2c brand I'm gonna create another d2c
brand or I run one company and I'm just
gonna run it for 15 20 years or um you
know I did a newsletter business I'm
gonna do another newsletter business and
that's repeat entrepreneurship and so
I personally have tried parallel
I've tried serial
I haven't really tried repeat I've
stayed away from that one I think if you
wanted order of in order of most likely
to succeed repeat is number one
serial number two parallel number three
and in terms of fun parallel is number
one serial is number two repeat is
number three and so I actually think
that the correct decision for me is
cereal it's the has enough fun and
enough winning uh that that's the that's
the choice versus going for maximum
success probability or maximum fund with
lowest success profit
which idea do you think would have been
the one that you should have stuck with
at Monkey Inferno
I think for the most part it was ideas
that we weren't we
well we should have done so what we did
do versus what we should have done what
we did do was we tried to create Hit
social apps why because before that the
the main the guy who was running it who
hired me and the guy who uh became the
main investor or was the main investor
they had built a social network called
bibo they had competed with Facebook and
Myspace back in the Heyday of social
networks they sold it for 850 million
dollars Facebook went on to become worth
850 billion dollars and there was always
this sort of like Shoulda Woulda Coulda
and at the time people were pretty down
on Facebook it felt like there was gonna
be something new but nobody knew what it
was and sure enough turned out to be you
know Instagram then Snapchat then uh
Tick Tock eventually and so new things
did come out that part was right but the
wrong part was trying to recreate
re-chase that dream because it was just
so low chances of success
so we build messaging apps and social
networking apps and all this stuff and
it just was really really hard to get it
to work uh what we should have done was
we should have built either tools for
startups or tools for developers because
we knew what the pain points of an early
stage startup were and we had a bunch of
developers we had like 18 developers and
so it was like we could have built
products that what was the total budget
what was your budget for the do you know
like three million four million I think
we burned about three to four million a
year
um in funding and which isn't that much
money for for 20 people well we also had
uh it wasn't fully 20 uh 20 was like
where it got to at the peak but also I
would say the core team was like let's
say 15 people so 15 people I think you
could do math maybe I have it longer
there was I don't know if that was
pre-taking into account the profits from
one of our businesses so we also
revamped one of his early businesses
that was his cash cow birthday alarm and
birthday alarm was making millions of
dollars uh profits before it had been
declining year over year for five years
straight we kind of like revamped it try
to turn it around and got it back to you
know slightly growing basically at that
by the time I left and so
um that covered a portion of the bird so
I don't know if the three or four
million was pre-that or post that I
remember at this point it's been six or
seven years since I was doing that which
was there uh was there a developer tool
idea that you thought you should do but
you didn't and someone else came and
took the opportunity so I'll tell you
three ideas that I think would have
worked that we had that we literally
discussed and had the idea for uh the
first was uh user testing so I used a
very early pro version of user testing
and I was like hey this is a pain point
for a startup like like the the company
the company user testing which is
basically like I could pay a hundred
dollars and I could get four people to
go try our app talk talk through it
because they would find bugs they would
tell us if they liked it or if they
didn't like it they would tell us what's
confusing about it and I was like these
videos are amazing like this is saving
me so much time versus having to go in
the wild and find literally fine people
stand over their shoulder and watch them
do this or just guess and I was like
this is a super useful service and I
told uh Michael that one day I was like
hey I think we should build this for
startups and I think we could outpace
them in terms of marketing because we're
here in Silicon Valley we understand the
startup game like we're we would be good
at getting early stage companies to use
this and usertesting.com is like a multi
hundred million dollar a year business
now yeah yeah exactly it went public at
a period of time hey we're public I
think it went back private now
um but yeah it was a it turned out to be
a big success you know eight years later
uh like they they took it all the way
and took it to IPO and he was like yeah
could do seems kind of boring right and
I was like too young and weak and I I
was 24 years old and he was my hero and
he was you know my boss at the time kind
of thing and I was like yeah yeah you're
right you're right you're right you're
right dumb sorry sorry sorry I even said
that right like I backed off it right
away same thing happened with cryptos
2013. our sis admin the the guy who's
running like our whole server setup was
like
guys I'm mining Bitcoin on this server
and we're like mining what and he tells
us why Bitcoin is going to be the next
big thing all of our all of our
Engineers were like yeah this makes
sense we love this
um and our team loved it and what our
CTO was like hey no normally this guy
never had product ideas he was like tell
me what to build I could build anything
he's like I got an idea and I was like
oh Paul's got an idea fantastic
let's hear it he's like
um Bitcoin I think is going to be a
thing and there's like no there's only
one exchange there's a startup called
coinbase but like they're just getting
started and he's like I think we could
build either an exchange or one of the
other like financial services for this
like cryptocurrency industry and he's
like they don't he's like you it's hard
to take a payment you know you can't
take credit card you can't do any of
these things that you're going to want
to do to enter like for a human being to
use crypto and he's like we should just
start building Financial Services let's
start with an exchange and then let's
see maybe we could do you know debit
cards on-ramp off ramp like what can we
do and he was so motivated he built like
a prototype overnight he got he he
started coordinating with his designer
he like shoved the product manager into
a corner it was like you know shut up I
got this and it was like a great sign
for a startup when the engineers are
like I know what needs to be built here
I I intuitively understand
and then our lawyer our in-house counsel
called up uh our investor was like Hey
the guys are talking about Bitcoin I
Googled it I think it's for drugs and
like you know I don't know if this is
the right idea so he came in he was like
you know
I don't mind losing the you know three
or four million dollars we spend on on
whatever like that's okay that's an
acceptable bird but I'm not going to
jail but I'm not trying to go to jail
and I'm not trying to do like money I'm
not trying to handle like money in
serious like ways like this
um I think like Bitcoin isn't this like
snake oil I don't know and I like kind
of can I convinced him enough that day
to buy Bitcoin I think like he was
basically like I don't know sounds a
little sketchy
he like bought some as a hedge but he
was like I don't think we should do I
don't think we should be in the Bitcoin
business because you need to you need
licenses to do this you're basically
talking about building a bank it's a
super gray area uh I I'm not trying to
lose my billion dollars like I can lose
the 3 million I can't lose my billion
and I was like dude the message I got
block Michael Bert she just blocked
you guys hard I I don't mean to blame
him the the mistakes were all on me I'm
just I recalled two examples where I
think we had good ideas that we did that
was the third one see through the third
was
we had built blab into a business that
was like a really good video chat
product
and uh
it was it got to four million users so
it was like kind of a thing so it was
basically like if you see Clubhouse
today or like uh Zoom today it was like
basically like a zoom caller Google
Hangout four people could be on the
screen talking but there was like a live
audience and anybody could kind of
request to join and jump in from the
audience and start talking so you could
do like calling shows and like that
uh and it got pretty popular like Tony
Robbins was using it like famous bands
were using it the UFC was using it
Martin's Corelli Martin shkreli was
using it yeah exactly
um and so we had we got to four million
users but it was like
so we thought maybe this is that thing
that big social product that we've been
waiting for but it was pretty clear to
me that
it was too leaky everyone was high yeah
sure was gonna be too high people
weren't going to use this every day or
the people who did use it every day they
were there just to make friends so
therefore it wouldn't grow because they
didn't bring friends they were there to
make friends and so you have this
problem where
um if you're if you're sticky users are
people who are there to meet people
they're not going to bring people
and so you're either not going to grow
and you're gonna have stickiness or
you're going to grow and you're not
gonna have stickiness was the problem we
ran into which is why by the way when I
wrote that thread that went viral
calling explaining why Clubhouse was not
going to work back when Clubhouse was at
its peak the reason I knew that was
because we had built a very similar
product and run into all those same
issues and sure enough it's all playing
hey so you didn't get rich but at least
you got kind of popular on Twitter
so there's that what's the it's like I
just dropped 400 at Chuck E cheese and I
got this like you know a little a little
slinky laser pointer yeah yeah
so that's cute you guys you have your
little Twitter thing that's nice exactly
so so that was the thing there the move
there would have been to shift towards
like Citrix was the big Citrix had a
thing called WebEx which is like they're
like uh video chat like for meetings and
that was horrible webinars and the
obvious thing was we had built a way
better tool for webinars or or like kind
of large company chats like uh All Hands
meetings and things like that if we had
pivoted to B2B basically
um
we genuinely had a like sort of like you
know 5x better product than them at the
time and I think we could have made it
successful we even had the idea we were
like should we do this we're like uh
kind of got to do sales and I don't
know like do we want to do that are we
are we a B2B company now and I was like
nah we'll just try again to build the
next big social app which was you know a
giant mistake hey you're not flying
private and you don't have a vacation at
home in Tahoe but at least you learned
at least you learned
you know if you're not winning you're
learning
books it's a memoir called at least I
learned
dude I hate when people say winning or
learning I'd rather win I don't want to
learn I'd rather be a dumb winner than a
smart loser
all day of the week
that's easy I'd rather be winning on my
plane but barely know how to read
um this is why I love this pod you get
stories like that those are good stories
yeah I think we should uh should wrap it
up there but tell me one thing what's
that say on your shirt awesome baby
all right we gotta start getting back
into that stuff uh I've been out of the
game but anyway good pod that's the
episode
[Music]
foreign